[Musique]
encore moins quand tu mettais au pays de
gêne à dire un scoop du hem le surprise
avons des rhinites mandaté une ola là
[Musique]
j'ai dit elle encore sortis seuls face
au feu rattraper je voulais lui montrer
les ordres du grand yaka pouvait
l'attendre
où est-elle allée au désert comme chez
ma cuisine de campagne
il faut que je m'en serve à titus je
vais lui faire une surprise
[Musique]
rambur et 1100 les bras d'un grand
groupe comme une vraie coucou devine
quittait aux sétois six mois la revue
même jour il sortait son père monsieur
j'ai bien fait chiper une découverte
extraordinaire
olemps houria de couvrir rolland a tu
crois qu'ils étaient jeudi de faire une
surprise moi y compris pour toi la
mienne d'abord cette caste yeux et tu me
suis beauvais nous donne moi la main je
suis dans l'oise mois où allons-nous
bien il ne pose pas de questions tu
regarderas car nous serons arrivés
tu encore loin nous apprécions
mon gâteau autorisant la nation et une
volonté de lignum retouches
quand on se trompe en salle au grand
yaka aux grands corps au superbe but
mais non mais non je suis arrivé en
retard et c'est formidable
et n'est ce pas quitus aux voix la f3000
table sans vous un money vous ne sais
vous j'ai été très bien et très
courageux si tu l'avais vu partir
desquels m'a vu il m'a aussi beaucoup
grand yaka merci non mais ne va pas par
là tu vas encore te faire capturer par
cette grande île merci beaucoup grand
yaka martin du touch
tu as besoin de ma production je ne te
quitte plus longuement quand vous trouve
pessimiste mais si tu veux te protège
allez va où tu veux je te tuer un bon
nous parle à savoir si les armes aux
cendres sont toujours à leur place
bon alors en avant marche je suis
content si je suis le plus courageux je
suis le plus bas et je suis le plus
courageux qui emmène titus au secours
yaka je le déteste je le déteste
ils vont voir les arbres c'était ma
surprise pour tutu où se trouve le cas
je le déteste
sinon on va voir qui est le plus
courageux des deux voilà longtemps à
arriver et tu vois l'attitude et je te
tiennent toujours es tu vraiment très
courageux n'est ce pas le prêtre est
beaucoup énormément cours av
nous ne demandons où vous trouvez tout
son courage et et la main à la souris à
la souris je sais qu'on a c'est pour
l'artiste qu'est ce que tu dit ça rodez
campaign to ruin fait opérer mais c'est
quelqu'un de même
et après après cette notre toit
[Musique]